I must show a couple days ago we
discussed the effort to that's been
going on for quite some time now to
erase our national history and to indict
the heroic figures who built our
civilization and I pointed out that
while the pioneers explorers conquerors
settlers pilgrims founders were not
perfect by any stretch of the
imagination
they still accomplish great things and
many of them were great people and so we
should look to them admire them honor
them and yes build statues to them and
everything and I also pointed out that
while we hold
you know these Western figures to this
modern standard we hold them to a modern
standard especially on on racial issues
that we spit on their graves graves if
they don't live up to it while we do
that you don't find that in any other
country in any other code that's not
going on any other country or culture
it's only in the West they're not doing
the same thing with their own heritage
and their own historic heroes and we
don't expect them to so I went to on the
show I went into extensive detail just
as an example talking about how many
Native American tribes and civilizations
were unspeakably brutal murderous in
some cases cannibalistic they raped
enslaved destroyed you know human
sacrifices so on and so forth yet nobody
would ever tell a Native American not to
be proud of their heritage nobody would
tell them not to honor their historical
heroes their historical figures that
only happens in the West
so I want to expand on that conversation
now a little bit and talk about the real
problem that arises when we start to do
this when we go back and we censor the
past and we condemn our ancestors and
the people who built this civilization
when we start doing that a really big
problem happens when we make essentially
a cartoon of the past when we make
caricatures of our historical figures
and we make them into these kind of
villainous cartoons there's a big
problem
I want to talk about what that problem
is and as an example of this phenomenon
and of the problem itself let's talk
about this situation with Laura Ingalls
Wilder who of course was a famous author
in the mid 19th century early 20th
century
she wrote The Little House on the
Prairie books but now the American
Library Association is dropping her name
from a prestigious children's award that
that they'd be giving out for I don't
know 50 or 60 years they've had her name
on it and they're taking her name off
and there's this process now of kind of
banishing her from from the children's
literature space because of her
culturally insensitive writings so I
want to read quickly a quote from Jim
Neel the president of the American
Library Association he's explaining this
decision he says Wilders books are a
product of her life experiences and
perspective as a settler in America's
1800's her works reflect dated cultural
attitudes toward indigenous people and
people of color that contradict modern
acceptance celebration and understanding
of diverse communities well geez I mean
that's surprising isn't it
that somebody who was writing in 1905
would have a dated perspective on
something I mean that's totally shocking
isn't it and then if you're wondering
well what what are these horrible things
that Laura Ingalls Wilder wrote there's
a New York Times article that describes
some of Wilders offenses I'll read a
little bit of it it says in the 1935
book Little House on the Prairie for
example multiple characters espoused
versions of the view that quote the only
good Indian was a dead Indian in one
scene a character described as Native
Americans as wild animals on desert
undeserving of the land they lived on
little town on the Prairie published in
1941 included a a description of a
minstrel show with Phi quote five black
faced men in raggedy taga t uniforms
alongside a jolting illustration of the
scene
Debbie Reiss a scholar who's writing and
research focuses on portrayals of
American Indians and children's
literature says there's this very subtle
but very clear fear generated throughout
the books and she says it's not
appropriate for young students maybe for
high schoolers but not for young
students so
in other words the characters in her
books had attitudes
that the people in that time and in that
setting would have had
and that's a problem
you see because we're not allowed to
acknowledge that anymore we have to hide
our children from it in shame if they we
have to shield them from it you think
about all the things we don't bother
shielding children from anymore I mean
all the it's like you've got people
parents and particularly school
administrators and teachers who think
there's nothing wrong with introducing
children to the most depraved sexual
ideas and sex acts imaginable at very
young ages
but oh no I you know an unflattering
portrayal of Native Americans and a
children's book will that I mean that is
just no we can't do that so of course
all these books have to be gotten rid of
and any person well any white person we
should say who may have possessed such
attitudes back in the day must be
posthumously exiled from polite society
that's what we're doing and it's
complete madness I mean it is total
madness to be doing this
and I'll explain why first of all
on the issue of historical racism and I
know this might be a little bit
upsetting for people to hear because I'm
going yes I'm going to make the case
that for a for a white settler in the
1800s
or a or a pilgrim in the 1600s or a you
know an explorer conquistador in the
1500s for them to have racist attitudes
was not those racist attitudes were not
as bad as the racist attitudes that you
might find today in other words it is
worse for you and I to be racist than it
was for them
they're there their moral guilt for
their racism was I think severely
mitigated by many different
circumstances
because you know if you're watching this
or listening to this right now and
you're not racist well then I mean good
for you congratulations if I had a
cookie I would give it to you I mean you
know go get yourself a cookie for not
being racist Congrats you're a wonderful
person on the thumbs-up on not being
racist wonderful good for you just you
should be so proud but that's not an
achievement that is not a moral
achievement on your part being rate for
most of us being racist was never even
really like an option we just we grew up
in a world where for a lot of us anyway
we grew up in an environment where it
just never even came up and never even I
mean it never even occurred the most I
never even occurred to me to be racist
they just I just and and if it ever did
occur to anyone you also grew up in a
society where racism is extremely
socially unacceptable and it will be
socially punished maybe even legally
punished in some circumstances so it was
never really never really occurred to
anyone to be racist that's that's not
the world that we live in so it means
you you deserve absolutely no credit
whatsoever for not being racist that is
just kind of a bare minimum thing in our
society so it doesn't afford you the
high moral position that you think it
does okay doesn't give you the the
position where you could stand up on
your pedestal and look down on
historical people and say well tisk tisk
tisk look those horrible people with
their racist attitude I'm so much better
than them no it doesn't give you that
doesn't give you that position
um because the fact is this almost
everybody in the world up until about
1960 was racist by our definition of the
term almost everyone I mean they were
all racist the idea of universal racial
equality is very new it is uniquely
modern it is uniquely Western even now
today currently there are many places in
the world where that does not exist
there are many places where world war
racism is still mainstream and most of
those places are non-western places
racism was and still is incredibly
common in some non-western non-white
cultures
but let's look at this historically
prior to the mid 20th century racism was
largely a given for most people across
the world across the races I mean if you
think for a minute that this was unique
to white people then you really are just
a an incredible fool and I don't mean
that as an insult just mean that you
really are a fool I mean some people are
fools and you'd be a fool a complete
total fool who's never read a book in
your life if you actually think that oh
so it's not just a white person think
even the people that we credit with
being reformers and progressives when it
comes to racial issues even they would
be if you were to take those people and
pluck them from their from their home in
you know the the the 19th century or the
18th century whatever you were to take
them and then put them into 2018 they
would be slobbering backwards insane
bigots by our standards today Abraham
Lincoln is credited with freeing the
slaves well you know what he also he was
also in a vowed racist he's on the
record saying he doesn't believe that
blacks and whites are equal he doesn't
want to see social and political social
or political equality in fact what he
wanted to do is he wanted to ship all
the slaves back to Africa now if you
were to take that position and Abraham
Lincoln is admired by almost everyone as
being this you know someone who believed
in equality and so forth but if you were
to take Abraham Lincoln
and put him in 2018 and have him run a
campaign
on the on the in his can one of his
campaign platforms is well white black
people are aren't equal let's ship all
the black people back to Africa well
that no I don't think it would be as I
don't think we'd be celebrating him
anymore would we by the way grant
General Grant was probably less racist
than even Abraham Lincoln but he was
also a an anti-semite
famously grant issued an order expelling
all the Jews from from the areas that he
controlled in western Tennessee
and again he's looked at as a figure of
you know a basically progressive figure
when it comes to race and as someone who
helped to liberate the slaves but this
is how ingrained this kind of bigotry
was that doesn't make it okay but it
does put it into context we have to see
it in the context of the time
and so know if everybody in the world is
racist and that's just how you looked at
the world does that make racism okay no
it doesn't does it severely mitigate
your personal moral guilt for being
racist absolutely it does I mean is it
really so shocking think about it today
you know we look at the we have a very
we have a very global perspective of the
world today we look at the world as a
world we see and we you know there is no
race but the human race and so forth I
mean we're all one species we're all one
race and it's all one world and that's
how we see things and that's it's
correct that's the correct way to see
thing we also have an understanding of
biology and science we have an
understanding that historical people
didn't have and we also have a
perspective that they didn't have they
didn't have a global perspective they
didn't think of the world as the globe
they thought of the world as the area
where they live they thought of the
world as their civilization their
culture so you know in ancient Roman who
would have said that Rome controls the
entire world well it never controlled
anywhere close to the entire world but
that's how they would have seen it look
that's the world this is your
civilization it's the world so for them
and again that's not a white it's not
how white people saw it's how everybody
saw it
so for them to come upon a new race or a
new world to stumble upon a new
civilization well for that process that
clashing of civilizations that would be
akin to modern people traveling to
another planet and encountering an alien
species that it's comparable with that
so when white pioneers met Indians you
can't compare that to you go into the
supermarket and being in line with
someone of a different race okay that's
not what it was like for them it was
like for both both sides Indians whites
it was it was more comparable to
encountering a whole new species a whole
new just it's like it's like these
people came from a different planet
that's what both of them were thinking
and you know what if that were to happen
and one of these days we do stumble upon
some other race on another planet which
won't ever happen but if it if it did
and we saw that you know they're like us
in some ways but they're also very
different in others and then we saw that
perhaps they engaged in practices that
are to us horrifying and
incomprehensible and brutal and savage
which you know some of the pioneers and
settlers and conquerors they would have
seen that's how they would have seen
human sacrifices and scalping and
cannibalism but if we were to encounter
that with this we know with this
hypothetical alien race who they look a
lot like us but not but they're also
profoundly different and how they look
they're very different and how they act
how they speak their customs and
everything if that would have happened
for us there would be a very real debate
among us about whether or not these
creatures are equal to us that would not
be a given under any circumstance when
the astronauts came back from from
Planet X and they met they met the
aliens they told us about him it would
not be a given among all of us that oh
yeah well they're just like us there
would be a real debate about the moral
standing of this alien species and if we
were to come to the conclusion that
they're you know they're not like us
they're we may come to the conclusion
that oh they're like animals where we
may come to the inclusion that oh
they're actually like gods because
they're technologically advanced we'd
probably be we would be wrong in those
conclusions but they're not crazy
irrational conclusions they're kind of
understandable conclusions because of
our lack of information because we have
encountered this mind-boggling new race
of creatures and we know nothing about
them
so we're coming to a sweet we we form
assumptions those assumptions might be
wrong
but considering our lack of information
they're also kind of understandable so
for people in history white black brown
all races for them when they met that's
what it was like it was like
encountering an alien from outer space
it was not immediately obvious to these
people to them that the other people
were equal
and you can sit there and you could say
well that's unacceptable they should
have known better
but that's the key known they didn't
know they were ignorant they didn't have
all the information
you have all the information and you
live in a society where racism is
totally unacceptable
they don't have the information and they
live in a society where it's just a
given
and you know what even though we have
all the information and we have all the
science we still get this wrong don't we
we still even now we still make the same
mistake because half of the people who
are shocked at Laura Ingalls Wilder for
having unflattering views of Native
Americans half of those people would
look at unborn human beings and say well
they're not really people
and they have no excuse they have all
the information they have the scientific
enlightenment and they're still making
the same mistake that they condemn Laura
Ingalls Wilder for or they condemn the
pilgrims for well guess what the
pilgrims had an excuse you don't second
thing the other really big problem with
this attitude of erasing our past and
turning historical figures into cartoon
villains and refused it and you know and
and and refusing to look at their sins
in proper perspective the other problem
is that we lose the opportunity to learn
from the past and to learn from these
people and I don't mean well learn from
the past or you're doomed to repeat it
I don't mean that that's not what I'm
talking about you know I don't really
like that I've never liked that phrase
honestly because it carries with it an
implicit bias against the past it
assumes that number one the only lessons
we can learn from the past are negative
lessons and number two that the worst
thing that could ever happen is that we
end up being like our ancestors were I
don't agree with that I think there are
positive lessons to learn from past and
I think that in a lot of ways we we
would be served very well if we were if
we were more like our ancestors not when
it comes to racism but when it comes to
many other things you know it's kind of
like saying well learn from your parents
or you're doomed to be just like them
which yeah if your parents are bad if
you have bad awful parents then that's
good advice
because if your parents are awful then
the only lessons they ever taught you
are negative lessons and really the
worst thing that could ever happen to
you is that you end up being like them
but the past doesn't need to be a bad
parent
the past can also be a good parent
and you know if a man has a good father
then the advice you give him is learn
from your dad or you won't turn out to
be the same kind of man
so there were a lot of good men and good
women in the past a lot of heroes and we
would do well to look at their positives
so that we can emulate them and
hopefully turn out to be like them or at
least mostly like them - things like
racism that's not to say that we should
idolize the past we shouldn't do that
either but I don't think there's there's
not much of a temptation these days to
idolize the past there's much more of a
temptation to idolize the present and
the future and to assume that whatever
is now must be better and whatever
happens tomorrow must be better still
now that's that's an idol that that is
making an idol of the of the present and
future and I would submit that that's
even worse in some ways than ancestor
worship but I'm not talking about
ancestor worship I'm talking about
looking at our ancestors in context in
perspective and accepting that there
were great men and women in the past
even if they had flaws even if they were
racist there were still great men and
women and we could learn quite a bit
from them we could learn positives
lessons lessons from them if we would
look at them and stop turning them into
cartoons and saying oh they were just
all racist so they were terrible that's
all they were I mean we're taking these
complex people who did incredible things
and we're boiling everything down to oh
they were racist not understanding that
by that logic we have just dismissed
everybody in history not just them but
everybody if that if on that basis we
can dismiss an entire person from the
past then we're dismissing basically
everybody
um the Little House on the Prairie is a
perfect example because you could look
at those books or a child could
especially and you could learn quite a
bit about family values hard work
responsibility self-sacrifice yet we
throw all those lessons away we dump
them down the drain because a child may
also learn that people of that time had
unflattering views about other races and
I find that very foolish because we're
getting rid of all the positive lessons
because of one bad thing
and there I mean take a figure like
someone I personally admire Stonewall
Jackson he was a man of incredible
integrity uh in an intensely religious
man dedicated to his wife to God to his
men he was a brilliant military
commander I think the best in the Civil
War one of the best in American history
one of the best in Western history and
we could look to him and we could learn
quite a bit we could learn positive
lessons from him this country would be a
better place if there were more men like
Stonewall Jackson in
but there won't be
because we take Stonewall Jackson we
tear down his statues we look with
contempt upon him we make him into this
ridiculous stereotype of a racist
southerner and all the positives that he
could teach us we just throw away we
just tossed them in the garbage because
of the racial issue everything else but
also we take that that's what he becomes
everything else throw it in the
incinerator
and we do this with almost every white
historical figure we drain the value the
educational value out of every
historical figure every era every event
by making them into easy villains we
lose the whole point
of the history book when we erase
everything in the history book and we
replace it with sketches and crayon
which is essentially what we've done
and most people now and most children
are being raised to have this
cartoonish drawn in kranj perspective or
view of guys like Stonewall Jackson or
Laura Ingalls Wilder or which wasn't a
guy but you know I'm saying to have this
cart the sketched in cran view of these
historical figures and so
we are we are cheating ourselves out of
the opportunity to learn and we're
cheating them out of the legacy that
they have earned
through the kind of people that they
were and the achievement the things that
they accomplished
I think it's a terrible mistake
well I'm on vacation for the next week
so have a good week everybody and I'll
talk to you in a little while
Godspeed